[Music]
hi Rita Moffett I taste Scalise closest
tastes Eleni case welcome that is
students of the beautiful Greek language
Ross McGowan car enemy nest in Hamas
Cayenne THAAD Catherine kadhi dusk
entertain amber ASEAN glow Sun it's my
great pleasure to see you here and to
teach this immortal tongue malonic casa
me
i am a loony costs which is the ancient
Greek word for Miller which is what my
surname Mueller means in the original
German I am honored to serve as your
deed us Kalos your teacher and have you
as my students my mother ty and if you
think that Moffat I sounds like math you
are a quick studies indeed our word math
derives from the greek verb month on oh
i learn and we have a lot to accomplish
today Moffet i the greek alphabet and
what we call the restored classical
pronunciation of ancient greek doubters
and skeptics and i can see you out there
may wonder how we could possibly know
how homer may have pronounced the
letters almost three thousand years ago
or perhaps plato a half a millennium
later in athens or after another five
hundred years when the Apostle Paul
penned his letters oh ye of little faith
you're right of course so much time so
many territories so many authors and
works Homer's Iliad and Odyssey Sappho's
love poetry Pindar's victory ODEs Greek
tragedy and comedy Herodotus the father
of history some say lies Plato Aristotle
lyric poetry the Gospel writers the
Apostle Paul Plutarch's lives of the
famous Grecians and romans and we are
just getting started
did they all pronounce Greek the same
way
do we all pronounce English the same way
in Australia the UK Scotland Ireland
Canada India Africa or even the USA
languages are messy especially over time
and across many places nevertheless we
shall today learn one pronunciation that
will apply to all the Greek we read we
call it the restored classical
pronunciation this pronunciation differs
significantly from modern Greek which
after the downfall of Constantinople in
1453 and the revival of classical
learning in Europe was the original
model but then a scholar by the name of
Erasmus set off a firestorm among
scholars by arguing in Latin for what we
call the restored classical
pronunciation this pronunciation remains
the standard in American colleges and
universities and we will use restored
classical pronunciation in this course
although we will truth be told
make some concessions to the sounds of
American English and if you speak
another variety of English or another
language altogether please embrace
whatever adjustments work for you
language should be an instructive
pleasure not a torture the important
thing is to pronounce Greek loudly
confidently relatively accurately and
consistently this will allow us to enjoy
Greek as a language we can focus more on
reading than on speaking ancient Greek
but we certainly aim to pronounce words
and sentences aloud in a way that is
recognizable as the restored classical
pronunciation even if our pronunciation
might have marked us as tourists to
ancient speakers of Homeric or a decor
Dora Corre alla chorionic or modern
Greek in the grammar that we learned in
this class will serve as a solid
foundation for reading Greek from Homer
in the 800s BCE to classical attic in
the fifth century BCE to the common
literary dialect or Koine
the aaalac dose that became standard
after the conquests of Alexander the
Great the new testament would eventually
be written in this dialect which we
simply call point a there are other
dialects too but we will keep our eye on
what is most common and useful
we take Homeric Greek as our starting
point and we will aim to learn these
forms thoroughly knowing the older forms
helps explain why later forms look the
way they do later Greek tends to
contract older forms we do the same
thing compare I'm going to go now which
becomes I'm gonna go now or even i'ma go
now contraction happens too many
languages we will thus look from time to
time at how Homeric forms eventually
settled on Koine forms by pausing
regularly to look at the New Testament
we will become acquainted with
contracted forms and between the earlier
and later forms we will acquire the key
to most literary Greek over a span of
thousands of years for all its varieties
Greek displays remarkable continuity and
words that Homer use can still be heard
on the streets of Athens today one small
example the word ton in Homer can mean
him in modern Greek dawn him in him and
these two are even still pronounced the
same way but leaving modern Greek aside
ancient Greek alone unlocks riches that
can only be appreciated by those who
know some Greek Shakespeare famously had
small Latin and less Greek but he had
some and after this course you will have
mastered the Greek verb and have read
lines of Homer's Iliad as well as
passages from the New Testament in the
original Greek an accomplishment that no
one will ever be able to take from you
but first the alphabet we have
course use the Latin alphabet which is a
descendant of a West Creek alphabet that
is why so many Latin letters look like
they're Greek counterparts the Greek
alphabet was itself developed from a
Semitic alphabet the first two letters
in Greek are alpha and beta hence our
alpha beta or alphabet but compare the
Hebrew letters Aleph and Beth and you
can hear the close kinship globalism and
cultural exchange are hardly exclusively
modern phenomena the classical Greek
alphabet has 24 letters we will leave
aside for now two archaic letters
although you can find them in the
guidebook if you're curious our first
letter is alpha which especially as a
capital looks just like our own letter A
it is always pronounced when long like
the a in father or when short more like
aa it is never ever pronounced like the
a and cake or the a and cat please
repeat alpha ah our next letter is beta
again not a problem
we will pronounce it like our own B
please repeat beta but by the way are
you repeating proud and out loud this is
important it is crucial to engage teeth
tongues lips the whole neuro
psychological apparatus of language from
brain to mouth two ears two hands two
eyes the more synapses you light up in
learning a language the better it sticks
please repeat out loud
we begin with letters but will soon move
on to words phrases and whole sentences
your own breath across vocal cords
tongue and teeth and lips has the power
to bring ancient Greek to life use your
power wisely and repeat proud and
outloud letter number three
gamma is equivalent to G the uppercase
looks like a gallows the lowercase a bit
more familiar gamma is always pronounced
hard gah as in girl never J as in
gymnasium please repeat gamma gut Delta
Delta is equivalent to D as in deal
please repeat Delta done epsilon epsilon
is equivalent to a short e as in pet
please repeat epsilon a Zeta Zeta is
equivalent to Z but Zeta buzzes more in
Greek because we should insert a D sound
as well tactically Z D as in Mazda but
it's a lot easier to say disease which
is what I generally do what can I say
I've got a bit of an American accent
please repeat
Zeta does ADA ADA is equivalent to the
long a in gate because this letter looks
like an H and a capital as a capital and
an N in the lowercase it will take some
study please repeat ADA a theta theta is
equivalent to th some choose to
pronounce theta as in aspirated T but
our T is in English are already
aspirated if I say for example the name
Tommy I put a puff of air after the T if
I take away that puff of air I would say
Brummie aspirated Tommy unaspirated
Tommy but I find that difficult and do
not want to pronounce in unaspirated T
for tau the Greek T so a th sound thaw
for theta is normal and common please
repeat theta the
iota iota is pronounced either as a long
e as in feet and police or a short I as
in hit please repeat iota E or a Kappa
Kappa is equivalent to K and pronounced
like the K in kill please repeat Kappa
Cup lambda lambda is equivalent to L and
pronounced like the L in language please
repeat lambda o mu mu is equivalent to m
and pronounced like the M in man please
repeat mu hmm nu nu is equivalent to n
and pronounce like the N in never it
looks a bit like our V so require some
study please repeat new mmm see some
call it zai but I prefer C C is a double
consonant equivalent to X that is a K
and s sound and pronounced like the X in
box please repeat c/o a crime is a small
oh a micro Oh which is to say a short Oh
like the Oh as in aught but a shorter a
closed o as in the British pronunciation
of but never as in my own native
Midwestern American that please repeat
on the cron Oh pi PI
equivalent to the P in PI please repeat
pi PI roh-roh
looks like a P but it's not Rho isn't
our if you can trill it the way they do
in the Mediterranean please do I on the
other hand a son of Wisconsin will
proceed with a good old American a
please repeat row row by the way if you
think this is going too fast it probably
is so please remember that you can
repeat this lecture as many times as you
like also you will find all of these
sounds spelled out in the guidebook so
you can study individual letters at your
leisure with me or without me as you
prefer Sigma Sigma is equivalent to s
and pronounced as the s in Singh not
however that there are three Sigma's
uppercase Sigma and to lowercase Sigma's
one lowercase Sigma looks like an O with
a pigtail and one is squiggly like our s
round pigtail Sigma is used everywhere
except the end of a word squiggly s
Sigma appears exclusively at the end of
words please repeat Sigma Tau is
equivalent to RT and pronounced as the T
in tip please repeat tau 2 Epsilon this
letter represents a sound that we don't
have in English
oops Alon should ideally be pronounced
as the U in French too or as in the
German word for Miller moola the other
hand the you in English prune may serve
as a close approximation please repeat
Epsilon
Phi is an aspirated P but again we
aspirate peas in English so if we were
to pronounce Phi as if it were an
aspirated P we'd have to take the
aspiration off PI and pronounce it by
life is too short
most students of ancient Greek pronounce
leaf I like the F sound at the beginning
of philosophy please repeat Phi Phi Chi
Chi is another sound that we do not have
in English its equivalent to a soft K
what makes a K sound but let's the air
seep through the back of the throat as
one pronounces it Chi Chi the air
escapes it's equivalent to the CH in
Scottish Loch or German doll if you
can't make this sound no worries
a simple case sound will suffice
remember no ancient Greek will ever make
fun of your accent and neither will we
please repeat Chi Sai Sai is another
double consonant equivalent to PS Sai is
pronounced like the PS at the end of
lips please repeat sigh and finally
Omega Omega is Big O mega o as opposed
to micro O or Omicron mega o is long
like the O in open please repeat Omega o
the first letter is alpha the last
letter is omega if you go from alpha to
Omega you go from beginning to end let's
recite the alphabet when I pause please
repeat Alpha Beta Gamma Delta Epsilon
Zeta Beta Theta Pi Oda Kappa lambda mu
nu C Omicron Pi Rho Sigma Tau
oops Elan Phi Chi Sai Omega and one more
time but this time we will practice the
sound of each letter please repeat alpha
R beta but gamma good delta duh epsilon
a Zeta D Zeta a theta da I Oh de e or e
kappa cut lambda o mu M nu hmm Sikhs
Omicron o pi pi Rho Sigma Tau Epsilon
ooh
Phi Phi Chi sykes Omega o there are a
few other sounds to learn namely some
vowel combinations called diphthongs but
let's practice a few Greek words first
that don't contain diphthongs our first
word means countless and is the origin
of our word myriad let's spell it mu
epsilon Rho iota Omicron Sigma did you
notice what kind of signal squiggly
Sigma at the end and what looks like a
lowercase P is really a row in our let's
read it aloud me Rios and again
Marie oz by the way the mark over the
iota is an accent please repeat mu Rios
each consonant is pronounced with the
vowel that follows it as a separate
syllable let's read it again mu Rios
this word means see as in a large body
of salt water but not an ocean let's
spell it theta alpha lambda alpha sigma
sigma alpha did you note the pigtailed
Sigma's in the middle of the word let's
try reading it Salah saw again the loss
saw and one more time Salah saw here's a
verb that means to put her to place
shall we spell it tau iota theta ada mu
iota
let's read it slowly T PHA me and faster
tithi me again three vowels three
syllables did you say e for the I Otis
one more time t-fame e unless do you
think every word has three syllables
here's a word for and or but Delta
Epsilon
please give it a try death again death
the epsilon is short please try to read
the Greek word for hero let's spell it
Aida Rho Omega Sigma but what are those
marks above the ADA we call them
diacriticals but that does not tell us
what they are
one diacritical looks like a quotation
mark and one diacritical looks like an
accent
the accent is an accent but what is the
curved mark the one that looks like a
quotation mark is a breathing mark there
are two kinds of breathing marks and all
words that begin with vowels have a
breathing mark over the first letter
breathing marks indicate whether the
letter is to be pronounced with an H we
call this rough breathing or without an
H which we call smooth breathing let's
compare and contrast the first Aida has
a mark that opens to the right the
second Aida one that opens to the left
the first Aida should be pronounced with
an H the second Aida should be
pronounced without an H let's read the
first Hey
please repeat Hey
now let's read the sack
a please repeat a time for a quiz try to
pronounce the ADA's correctly with or
without an H after a brief pause I'll
provide the answer are you ready hey hey
hey hey hey I think that we're ready to
try hero in Greek please repeat hey rose
and faster hey rose time runs a pace
let's look at what remains of ancient
Greek pronunciation diphthongs that is
two vowels sounded as one at the same
time there are nine tip things but only
seven sounds Alpha Iota is pronounced
like the AI in Aisle please repeat Alpha
Iota
I Alpha Epsilon is pronounced like the O
you in house please repeat alpha epsilon
out epsilon iota is pronounced like the
a in freight that is pretty much like
the ADA but we do not have a pure a
sound in English so most of us can't
hear the difference please repeat
Epsilon iota a epsilon epsilon or ada
epsilon is a two-for-one special
a long epsilon is represented as in ADA
so when combined with an epsilon they
both make the same sound which
unfortunately does not exist in English
it's like the EU in French flu or the OM
lout in German should equivalent to a
plus ooh
fused into one syllable ooh ooh but if
you'd like to settle for you that works
too we're not native speakers we have an
act
it please repeat epsilon epsilon or ada
epsilon ooh
[Music]
Omicron iota is pronounced like the oh I
in foil please repeat Omicron iota
Oy on the cron epsilon and Omega epsilon
is another two-for-one special little oh
and Big O combined with epsilon is
pronounced like the oh you in soup
please repeat
Omicron epsilon or Omega epsilon ooh
and finally epsilon iota is pronounced
like the English word we or the French
we please repeat oops Elan iota we have
you got all that of course not unless
you already know Greek which brings me
to an important point you're going to
have homework math Atty you'll find
summaries of the lecture and
supplementary exercises in the guidebook
it is essential that you complete the
exercises for each lecture before
proceeding to the next lecture practice
makes perfect and you are free to repeat
each lecture to as often as you like
let's repeat a few more words please
repeat after me and concentrate on each
letter or combination of letters as we
say the word please repeat ah he'll
loose again
ah he'll loose was that a smooth or
rough breathing before the Alpha smooth
the last syllable is a diphthong ah one
more time akka loose very good rule um
smooth or rough breathing smooth the
first syllable is a diphthong any
diacriticals go over the second foul of
a diphthongs please repeat ooh law meh
nose again
ooh la Mer nose one more time
luminous Ohio's smooth breathing second
syllables a diphthong accent is on the
last syllable please repeat
ah hi us again Ohio's olgas again olgas
por los again follows if the moss more
slowly if the moss
again if theme us okay again zu k ck pro
e up toe do you see the two dots over
the iota that's not an unload we call it
a dr asus and this is our final
diacritical it means that the iota is
pronounced separately from the preceding
Omicron rather than as the diphthong
oi please repeat pro e up toe four
syllables again pro e up toe and faster
proyecto he'll Orion
hey lo re on hell Orion - Co again to Co
oil nos three syllables
Oy Oh nos again I own us and finally log
us please repeat logos logos means word
which was according to John at the
beginning but for us it is at the end my
water clock has run out
please study the alphabet in the guide
book memorize the alphabet do the
practice exercises repeat the first
lecture as many times as you like and
when you feel comfortable visit me again
in lecture 2 but for now I must go
Mau Moffitt I come back soon farewell
students hi Rita Moffett ah